Adam Sandler may have made millions playing
lovable goofballs — but his personal life has
been marked by sadness and tragedy. From being
publicly mocked by his former bosses to losing
his closest friend, the "Billy Madison" star
knows what it's like to be at his lowest.
Adam Sandler landed a spot on "Saturday
Night Live" after proving himself as a
writer and appearing in a few movies and
television shows. His tenure on the sketch
comedy series coincided with one
of the show's most beloved eras.
Much to the dismay of his fans, however,
Sandler and Chris Farley left "SNL" after
the 1994-95 season. At the time, audiences
were left thinking that the two stars had
quit. But in recent years, Sandler has
exposed the truth of his exodus from the
late-night series. During an appearance on
"The Howard Stern Show," Sandler admitted,
"The NBC head dude, I know he didn't
like our gang, uh, me and Farley."
The actor also recalled how his manager let him
down easy about being fired.
Sandler revealed to Stern:
"At the time, I was hurt because I
didn't know what else I was going to do."
Thankfully, Sandler became a box office
sensation, and holds no grudges. He even
returned to host "SNL" in 2019, where he made
light of being fired with a musical monologue.
Fans may look back fondly on
Adam Sandler's five-year run
on "Saturday Night Live," but the actor
holds some deep regrets about his tenure
on the show. In an interview with AARP,
Sandler reminisced about his "SNL" days,
and expressed disappointment with much
of his early conduct. He told the outlet,
"I used to go nuts. I had a quick
temper, quick reactions. I made a lot
of dumb mistakes and said a lot of stupid
things. Looking back on relationships,
I could be an ass. I was selfish. I
was competitive with other comedians."
The actor also admitted that his
aggressive pursuit of fame left
him unable to acknowledge the
talent of his peers. He added,
"I was hungry, I didn't always see
clearly then. I wanted to be a big
comedian like Eddie Murphy,
like Rodney Dangerfield."
Thankfully, Sandler has matured
a lot since his "SNL" days,
and is no longer as competitive
as he once was. He told AARP,
"I appreciate other people's talent now rather
than competing. I'll watch somebody and say,
'Man, they're great. I never would have
thought of that joke or that approach.'"
Even though it isn't his first movie,
1995's "Billy Madison" is often credited as
launching Adam Sandler's huge film career.
"Stop looking at me, Swan!"
The movie is about a man-child forced to complete
several grade school classes in order to secure
his father's estate. It was also the first film
Sandler co-wrote with his screenwriting partner
Tim Herlihy. "Billy Madison" is considered a
classic today, but at the time of its release,
critics were not on board with Sandler's
immature antics and obnoxious energy. Notably,
Roger Ebert used the opportunity to
focus on the actor's screen presence,
comparing him to fingernails on a blackboard.
Sadly, Sandler was ill-prepared for the barrage
of negative comments, telling Deadline in 2022,
"When 'Billy Madison' came out, me and my
friend who wrote it [...] read the first
[review] and we were like, 'Oh my god, what
happened? They hate us.' And then we were like,
'It must have been this paper,' but then 90%
of the papers are going, 'This is garbage.'"
"I did stop reading them after that."
Since then, Sandler has been pretty hostile
towards critics and the media in general.
Adam Sandler has developed a notorious reputation
for avoiding interviews with the media — and
for good reason. The comedian can pinpoint a
couple of events early in his career when he
was misquoted, which resulted in his distrust for
journalists. He told The Harvard Crimson in 2000:
"One time I was in a room with a
person who kept going on and on
about how much he loved the movie.
That night, I see him on TV saying,
'This movie is useless.' And I'm like,
'Dude! That's the guy who was nice to me.'"
Another example of how the media has done
Sandler wrong came up during a 2023 interview
with the Washington Post. In the interview,
Sandler recalled a moment in 1995 when he
was quoted in TV Guide for saying the writing
on SNL was bad. Sandler recalled to the Post:
"I go, 'I never f---ing said that. I never
would say that.' I called the writer. I said,
'Why did you say I said that?'
And he kind of didn't want to
talk to me. I should have taped the conversation."
Since then, the actor has spent most of his
career avoiding interviews and critics. However,
he admitted to AARP that he's still
hurt by negative reviews, saying,
"Mostly because I invite all these amazing
people I care about to make movies with me,
and I wish they didn't have to read
s--- about whatever we've made."
At the height of his film career in 1999, Sandler
started Happy Madison Productions. From there,
he struck a long-term deal with
Sony Pictures, which saw him star
in 24 films for the company. However, things
didn't end so well between Sandler and Sony.
In 2014, Sandler signed a multi-picture deal
with Netflix, which essentially put an end to
his relationship with Sony. With a boatload of
money coming his way from the streaming service,
the maneuver seemed like a natural transition.
However, news soon came to light that there
was far more going on behind the scenes
between Sandler and his former distributor.
After malicious hackers raided Sony Pictures in
2014, emails featuring Sandler's name surfaced.
In discussions between Sony's heads, the comedic
powerhouse was described as a self-important jerk
whose best days were behind him. The actor
has never publicly addressed his falling out
with Sony or the emails, but after a longstanding
and fruitful relationship, that one had to hurt.
Adam Sandler would be the first person to admit
that he is not perfect. And throughout his career,
the actor has described many of the
personal challenges that he has had
to overcome. During an interview
with The Harvard Crimson in 2000,
the comedian admitted that he
has an anger problem, saying,
"In real life, I do have a bit of
that problem. But over the years,
I've been getting better I think."
Sandler also said he relates to
the "loser" characters he often
depicts on screen. He admitted
on the "Little Gold Men" podcast,
"I just have a natural part of my brain
that feels like I don't belong here. This
feeling uncomfortable and loser stuff
I've been doing for years, it's in me."
In recent years, Sandler has been proactive
in treating his mental health, telling AARP,
"I talk to a shrink sometimes. He's given me
a plan. Sometimes just holding in a sentence,
taking a beat for a minute before saying something
stupid. When I do that, I realize it wasn't that
important to say it in the first place."
With fame comes consequence. For Adam Sandler,
that means he spends a lot of time
dealing with legal disputes. For instance,
Sandler's 2008 film "You Don't Mess With
the Zohan" landed the actor in hot water
after cartoonist Robert Cabell claimed that
the lead character was plagiarized. The film,
which is about an Israeli counter-terrorist
commando turned hairdresser, did share many
similarities with Cabell's cartoon
"Jayms Blonde" In Cabell's cartoon,
the lead character is a Navy SEALs-trained
hair stylist who fights crime.
In 2013, Sandler and company were sued again by a
carpenter who lost his finger while building sets
for "That's My Boy." The complaint sought
$1 million for "gross negligence" after
Sandler's production company failed to provide
the proper safety equipment required for the job.
But Sandler's most drawn-out case involved
a professional nanny named Deanne McDonald
who he hired to care for his children.
McDonald originally settled a dispute with
Sandler out of court. The suit involved
undisclosed employment claims. However,
after breaching a clause in the settlement,
McDonald was ordered to repay the actor $80,000.
Since he's no longer a young performer,
Sandler has felt the signs of aging. The actor
started getting concerned about his physical
health while filming back-to-back features,
"Murder Mystery 2" and his upcoming
movie, "Spaceman." He told Variety:
"I was hanging in a harness all the time. I
kept saying, 'Something's going on with my hip,
man.' I was like, 'Yeah, I definitely gotta
x-ray that thing,' and we were in trouble."
The actor underwent hip surgery in September 2022
and was understandably in a lot
of agony for some time after.
"My hip surgery was painful."
Sandler also admitted that the
surgery made him feel "old." However,
when asked about how he felt after
surgery, the actor joked to "Page Six":
"I screamed a lot then calmed
down and ate some food."
It has become somewhat of a tradition for Adam
Sandler to cast his friends in his productions.
After all, "Grown Ups" and its sequel were
essentially conceptualized as an opportunity
to spend more time with his buddies. So,
there is no doubt that camaraderie is a
core value to Sandler. Unfortunately,
with over 70 film credits to his name,
the actor has had to say goodbye to many
co-stars throughout the years. Some of the
notable friends of Sandler who have passed
away include Bob Barker and Cloris Leachman.
There are a couple of deaths that hit
Sandler harder than others. Norm MacDonald,
who shared the stage with Sandler on "SNL" and had
his first movie credit on "Billy Madison," passed
away in 2021. After Norm's passing, a heartbroken
Sandler shared on X, formerly known as Twitter:
"Every one of us loved Norm. Some of the
hardest laughs of my life with this man.
Most fearless funny original guy we knew. An
incredible dad. A great friend. A legend."
Still, the most heartbreaking loss for Sandler
was the untimely passing of Chris Farley in
1997. After spending time on "SNL" together,
Farley was one of Sandler's closest confidants.
"Ravioli? Holy cannoli."
Sandler still misses his former
co-star and memorialized him with
a four-minute tribute song during his
hosting appearance on "SNL" in 2019.
"Something, just something very
powerful that night. And it felt,
felt great talking about Chris."
There is one thing that Adam Sandler
values above all else: Family. The actor gives
much of the credit for his success to the endless
support he received growing up. While accepting
the 2023 Mark Twain Prize for American Humor,
the comedian said there was one
thing that led him to the night:
"I come from a great family."
Tragically, Adam Sandler was hit with a
significant loss in 2003, when his father,
Stanley, passed away. The actor has held much
respect for his father throughout his career,
even using him as inspiration for his character
in 2022's "Hustle." He said to ET Canada:
"I was just basically doing my dad when
he used to coach my teams growing up,
his kind of demeanor. He'd push
you but then he'd also say like,
'All right, I see my kid's about to
snap, let me pull back a little bit."
Understandably, the former "SNL" star
was devastated by the loss of his father,
especially after watching his
health decline. Sandler told Parade:
"I went through stuff with my dad before he died.
I saw firsthand what goes on with
people who are incredibly sick."
The actor still holds a special place in his
heart for Stanley Sandler. In
a 2020 Facebook post, he wrote,
"My dad. The greatest man I ever knew.
Love you so dad! I know I was a mistake
but I know you had a good time! Thanks
for having me and miss you every day!"